alexisard bonjour à vous député
renaissance de l'Essonne merci tous les
deux d'ailleurs à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté le principe du débat en face à
face dans cette émission Nicolas hazard
votre premier sujet d'interpellation
André jacène concerne le dossier de la
très important de la réindustrialisation
bien sûr je crois qu'on sera d'accord
tous les deux là-dessus on a un besoin
de réindustrialiser le pays oui c'est
Alexis
donc Alexis
l'important est de parler de
réindustrialisation depuis deux ans les
résultats sont plutôt bons on a d'abord
on a réussi à stopper la
désindustrialisation du pays depuis 2017
depuis 2017 pardon et maintenant on voit
la création de nouvelles usines en
France donc on peut s'en réjouir on a de
la chance de voir la création d'emplois
la création d'emplois industriels et je
le rappelle un emploi industriel créé
c'est entre 0,8 et 1,5 emplois ind irect
qui se crée également donc c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour notre pays et
je pense qu'on sera d'accord sur ces
sujets là d'abord la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on parle enfin
de réindustrialisation c'est vrai que
pendant des années on en parlait pas
nous les comédies on a toujours porté ce
pour tes discours là donc on va pas dire
que de mauvaises choses d'en parler
faut quand même se rappeler qu'il y a
pas si longtemps en considéré que
c'était uniquement du tertiaire qu'il
fallait des usines sans salariés
pratiquement on était vers une approche
qui consistait à délocaliser pour faire
plus de profits donc on parle de
réalisation c'est une bonne chose par
contre je suis beaucoup beaucoup moins
optimiste sur les résultats obtenus on
les résultats obtenus ils sont pour le
moment assez limité je crois que les
seuls secteurs qui
qui en fait progresse pour l'essentiel
c'est il y a l'agro il y a l'industrie
agroalimentaire il y a les secteurs des
déchets il y a aussi l'eau mais le reste
c'est quand même extrêmement timide il y
a très peu très peu de progrès qui ont
été faits et notamment sur la des
relocalisations puisqu'on a beaucoup
parlé avec la crise du covid de
relocalisation je lisais il y a pas
longtemps que il y a une cinquantaine
d'entreprises seulement qui en
relocalisé qui ont représenté ensemble
800 emplois avec une moyenne donc de 16
emplois par entreprise et je pense que
pour le moment la grande priorité
devrait être organisations
plusieurs c'est 13 milliards d'euros qui
sont qui vont être investis pour
réindustrialiser c'est on est pour la
quatrième année de suite le pays dans
lequel les investisseurs étrangers en
Europe investissent le plus c'est une
bonne nouvelle on voit arriver beaucoup
d'industriels qui viennent créer des
usines de batterie dans le Nord ce qui
est très positif là-dedans c'est que les
industries reviennent dans les
territoires qui avaient été désertés et
dans lesquelles on voyait le chômage
énormément monter ils vont revenir ils
vont créer de l'emploi qualifié parce
que vous le parliez du tertiaire tout à
l'heure vous avez totalement raison un
emploi industriel il paye bien mieux
qu'un emploi du tertiaire aujourd'hui et
ça il faut qu'on arrive à le remettre
dans des jeunes et qu'on recrée cette
vocation d'industrie j'aurais préféré en
ce concernant l'industrialisation une
approche différente le sentiment que ça
me donne c'est qu'il y a je vais
utiliser un peu une image on fait un peu
la danse du ventre quoi pour attirer des
entreprises ces entreprises en les
attire avec bien sûr des avantages
extrêmement importants au niveau
fiscalité on les on les attire avec des
avantages que donc qui leur sont
accordés au niveau fiscal avec des aides
aussi d'ailleurs avec des aides
financières donc mais ces entreprises on
a il y a pas vis-à-vis d'elle on n'a pas
d’accord dans la durée et on a connu
dans le passé des entreprises qui
profitent qui profitent des faits
d'aubaine et qui en définitive ne reste
pas donc je suis un peu même si on peut
se réjouir quand la création d'emplois
j'ai pas une optimisme bien et d'autant
plus que souvent ce sont des ce sont des
entreprises qui vont venir chez nous qui
vont d'ailleurs aussi
peut-être englobé ça a été le cas des
gens sont prises américaines qui qui
englobe qui avalent des entreprises
françaises qui en même temps partent
avec les brevets on a pu la voir donc
faut être très attentif par rapport à ça
et je préférerais moins avoir une note
des marches qui serait une démarche plus
organisée territoriale
et pour la restauration
je pense que derrière tout ça je crois
que c'est faux vous le faites avec
enthousiasme je crois que c'est faux
pour deux raisons la première
et je suis persuadé que vous êtes
convaincu de ce que vous dites mais je
crois que derrière tout ça il y a
beaucoup de il y a quand même pas mal de
mousse
je ne suis pas d'accord pour deux
raisons d'abord la première étant que
ici on parle de réindustrialisation et
pas de capitaux je suis d'accord avec
vous quand les capitaux étrangers
arrivent dans les entreprises de
services on peut avoir peur qu'après les
compétences et qu'elles s'en aille ici
elles vont créer des usines elles vont
construire des usines du matériel qui va
être en quelque sorte ancré dans les
territoires et deuxièmement je vais vous
dire une deuxième chose c'est que si les
usines aussi les entreprises
réinvestissent en France c'est parce que
ce qu'on leur promet dans le projet de
loin industrie verte c'est pas plus
d'avantages fiscaux c'est une
simplification de l'arrivée en France
une simplification c'est pas plus
simplifier que la terre entière c'est se
mettre au niveau de nos voisins c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il fasse pas on n'est
pas besoin de 18 mois pour créer une
usine en France mais plus que 9 mois
c'est deux choses exactement ce qui se
passe en Allemagne c'est de se mettre au
niveau de nos voisins européens deux
choses par rapport à ça là j'ai
rapidement regardé la nouvelle la loi
sur la sur le projet de loi sur
l'industrie vert d'abord sur les
entreprises qui viennent très souvent ce
sont des entreprises d'assemblage et qui
vont impliquer des importations de pays
qui produisent à bas coût et j'aurais
préféré que il y ait une stratégie qui
consiste à voir des entreprises qui
créent plus de valeur en quelque sorte
avec avec une forme de avec une forme de
planification dans la durée il y a
justement cette nouvelle création de
valeur sur notre territoire qui est le
planification dans la durée on n'a pas
assez de planification là qui avait été
annoncé pourtant on a même d'ailleurs
une espèce de lutte entre les régions
c'est celui qu'offrira le plus
d'avantage pour pouvoir accueillir et je
pense que ça c'est pas forcément très
simple c'est ma première observation la
deuxième la deuxième sur le sur le
projet de loi de l'industrie vertes
c'est c'est vrai que il y a une forme de
simplification qui est faite mais une
simplification je me demande si
véritablement ça permettra de limiter
les délais peut-être peut-être mais je
ce que je voulais dire c'est que déjà
les délais qu'on a pour instruire les
dossiers qu'un entreprises de
s'installer chez nous c'est aussi par
qu'on manque de personnel dans un
administrations pour instruire en
l'occurrence vous l'accumulation des
démarches qui vont aujourd'hui être mis
en parallèle oui mais faut pas aussi que
ça se passe je prends l'exemple je crois
que c'est l'article peut-être l'article
7 j'en suis pas sûr ou l'article 9 il y
a un article dans ce projet de loi qui
en gros fera que l'État pour apprendre
la main sur les collectivités c'est
l'article 9 et c'est pas l'état qui
prend c'est l'article 7 c'était sur les
retraites voilà c'est l'article 9
l'article en question il prendra
c'est de faire en sorte que de la même
manière que sur les projets de
nucléaires qu'on a fait la loi de
l'accélérateur et celle de l'ENR en fait
l'idée c'est que sur les projets
d'intérêt nationaux c'est la même chose
pour les industries nucléaires et NR le
préfet puisse dire bah là il y a une
nécessité ça va dans le sens de la
planification que vous demandez de dire
sur notre territoire on a besoin de
cette technologie ça pourrait être le
cas dans le Nord où on a besoin d'usine
de batterie par exemple mais vous de
dire on a besoin de cette
réponse est après une question sur
je pense qu'il faut quand même qu'on ait
confiance en nos élus locaux et il
assassin des maires de France a émis de
fortes réserves par rapport à ça en
estimant que les élus ont cette volonté
bien sûr d'attirer des entreprises y
compris des entreprises vertes comme on
dit et qu'il faut être attentif à ce que
il y ait pas une volonté de l'État qui
ne respecte pas les choix qui sont les
choix des collectivités territoriales
moi je suis socialement parce que les
Français d'ailleurs sont très attachés à
ce sujet toute dernière question
j'ai commentaire là-dessus c'est de dire
que tous les projets d'industrie sur les
territoires ne seront pas soumis à la
main du préfet les élus locaux garderont
la main ce sera simplement pour les
projets d'intérêt nationaux
notamment sur les friches ça c'est
intéressant tout à fait oui sur la
réforme finalement qui va qui va en lien
avec ce projet de réindustrialisation
parce qu'on a besoin de compétences on a
besoin de créer des compétences et on
remarque que dans le lycée professionnel
on a un taux de décrochage au lycée
professionnel on a un taux de décrochage
à peu près trois fois supérieur au lycée
classique on a tendance à y emmener des
élèves par défaut alors qu'on a besoin
de créer des vocations je le disais tout
à l'heure un métier industriel c'est 10
à 15 fois plus rémunéré avec des
capacités d'évolution au sein de
l'entreprise et ça il faut donner envie
d'industrie c'est très fort moi je la
trouve catastrophique je la trouve je
prends un exemple vous avez un jeune qui
est dans un bac pro actuellement durant
les trois années de bac pro il aura je
crois 22 semaines de stage en entreprise
là le projet de loi va faire en sorte
qu'il aura le double il aura 44 semaines
alors c'est à peu près
attendez laissez-moi expliquer il y aura
à peu près le double de stage en
entreprise or le risque pour ma Kane
norme c'est qu'on sacrifie les
formations de base et conforme des
salariés qui soit des salariés sur un
seul métier alors qu'aujourd'hui un
jeune qui va rentrer dans la vie active
il faut savoir qu'il aura à faire cette
dix métiers différents peut-être que
dans les 15 ans qui suivent 50% des
métiers auront disparu il y en aura
d'autres et je pense
20 ans après une formation ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on va mettre les
jeunes dans une forme d'entonnoir et on
va les former pour un métier déterminé
parce qu'il y a des métiers sous tension
au moins ce que je considère c'est qu'un
jaune un jeune il soit capable durant
toute sa vie active et de pouvoir
évoluer ça sera pas le cas ça sera pas
l'idée de la réforme c'est pas ça l'idée
de la réforme c'est de dire que durant
la première et la deuxième année
ça ne change réellement si ce n'est que
les semaines de stage sont rémunérés en
seconde 50 euros par semaine payer par
première 60 payés par qui payez par
l'État par les sortes que les
entreprises continuent que les
entreprises continuent à les prendre et
lors de la terminale là il y aura deux
choix qui s'ouvriront c'est soit l'élève
veut continuer ses études aller vers un
BTS et dans ce cas-là il y aura plus
d'heures de formation
spécialiser dans un métier donc il y
aura plus de de stage en entreprise
l'idée étant d'être plus à la carte et
de faire profiter durant les temps de
formation à l'école aux jeunes d'une
formation plus qualifiées en petits
groupes pour faire en sorte sur les sur
les fondamentaux un jeune qui est en
troisième année donc un terminal de pack
pro si on lui propose d'aller faire je
sais pas deux mois ou trois mois de
stage en entreprise où il touchera je
crois ça sera 100 euros s'il est en
terminale sera 100 euros par semaine 100
euros par semaine le jeune
puisqu'ils sont pour l'essentiel issu de
mieux modeste tous les chiffres
toutes les statistiques montent se sont
essentiellement des jeunes
issus milieu modestes ils iront sur
cette voie-là ils iront sur cette loi
sur cette voie et ils seront dans un
entonnoir sur un métier et au lieu de
continuer leurs études et ensuite de
progresser dans leur vie
quand même que dénoncentrer peut-être
que vous pouvez améliorer la sensible
parce que bien au contraire c'est soit
ils choisira de faire une durée plus
longue de stage et dans ce cas là il
sera employable très vite la mesure est
de faire en sorte qu'ils sont appelés
soit ils choisira de faire un peu moins
employable pour un métier de faire un
peu moins de stage pour ensuite faire un
BTS qui prend en alternance
je lisais aussi des une étude par
rapport à ça il y a à peu près il a
grande majorité des entreprises ne font
pas des formations pour faire évoluer le
salarié quand on a un pays comme
l'Allemagne d'ailleurs quand on appuie
comme ce que je veux dire que si
en étant sur le tas en étant à son tour
s'il a pas eu les enseignements
fondamentaux qui sont donnés moi je
pense que ce projet de loi je pense que
ce projet de loi catastrophique je le
dis pour moi ce projet de loi c'est une
erreur du projet de loi et justement de
renforcer les fondamentaux en faisant
des petits groupes et je peux rappeler
aussi que même si rien n'est parfait
dans l'éducation n'est quand même la
première année ou après 15 ans de déclin
dans le niveau scolaire en primaire on
est la première année où ça se stabilise
alors c'est pas c'est pas les merveilles
c'est pas exceptionnel mais en tout cas
on voit que on a stoppé la dégradation
du niveau qui était en marge depuis 15
ans donc ça on peut s'en féliciter
maintenant il faut qu'on renforce
et pourtant
de collège j'ai deux filles qui sont
dans l'éducation nationale dans une qui
est professeur des écoles et ben ça ça
met pas remonté les constats qui sont
faits sur le terrain ne correspondent
pas toujours tout à fait c'est constat
là
merci infiniment d'avoir été là et
d'avoir animé ce